and now I'm going to introduce
our panelist says I do I asked you to
please join me up here and take a seat
first we have super Mayan Copa Raju or
subbu as he likes to be called su who is
vice-president head of software
engineering and technology labs or set
labs at emphasis and emphasis set labs
is the technology research arm of the
company
forging all the innovations and emphasis
is so famous for he also heads the
Microsoft Technology Center for emphasis
would you please come up next we have
latesh cut regatta Lalit's received his
master's and doctors degrees in computer
science and robotics from Carnegie
Mellon he was involved in the Carnegie
Mellon lunar rover program
he created a robotic startup which was
in acquired by Google and he's been with
Google ever since in fact he's the
founding Co Center head for Google's
Research Center here in Bangalore Lalit
Pradeep Khosla is an alumnus of Carnegie
Mellon receiving his PhD in ECE from
Carnegie Mellon and now serves as our
Dean of the kava Carnegie co technology
or the College of Engineering position
he's held since 2004 for deep-set a
phenomenal job as dean you'll get a
taste of that during the panel he's also
been an outstanding professor it
continues to be an active one he also
holds the chair of the Philip and
Marshall University professor he was the
founding director of the Scilab which I
referred to before in my remarks and
Isis which I also referred to and was
head of our ECE department before
becoming dean of engineering in 2004
he's received many awards including a
very significant award from the IIT
Alumni Association and was inducted
elected into the u.s. national academy a
couple years ago the highest honor an
engineer can receive in America Pradeep
Khosla harsh manglik is also an alumnus
having received his MBA from GSI a now
the tougher school he is also a parent
of a current student a student in our
Hines college harsh serves as chairman
of Accenture India as well as being the
geography managing director for India he
serves as the senior voice and manager
for all of Accenture activities in India
both focused on the India market and in
the way
Accenture India supports their global
businesses before that he worked at
Symantec Corporation in IBM in the US
for many years we're delighted he could
be part of this panel today
Hirsch bank
how about now excellent thank you okay
let me get us started here with a
question for you
subbu thank you for being here I'm not
picking on you because you're the only
non alumnus in the group but we're going
to start with you tonight you are an
honorary alum how's that but just for
tonight
his company course is known as when the
most innovative in the world emphasis
has had enormous impact in the world and
fantastic success story he attracts and
manages some of the brightest people in
the world and I have a couple of
questions for you in particular first of
all with regard to managing very bright
people or innovating what are your
biggest challenges in doing that and how
do you build and sustain a culture of
innovation within the company okay first
of all thank you very much for inviting
me here you already answered my question
I was wondering whether you really got
the right subbu gavarraju because I'm
the only non alumnus here but anyway
there cannot be too many people with the
same name yeah so thank you I think to
put it very simply the biggest challenge
is given the kind of business we are in
we are really in the business of as a
services organization we are really the
business of what I call innovatively
applying information and communication
technology in the context of the global
thousand level 2,000 kind of operations
so so again given the kind of business
we are in we also believe that
innovatively applying ICT can be a key
differentiator in the growth of an
organization so while there are
technology companies then the technology
users we are the people we are-- who are
really helping people in applying this
one so that as part of that we actually
worked with several technology creators
some could be very big platform
companies some could be startup
companies etc but I think in our case it
really boils down to the timing aspect
of that when is
a technology right for a solution for
universally applying in a context so
there are so many things going on so
many technologies available so many
startup so many big platform companies
but which are the given that there and
so many different kind of challenges
especially many of them articulated in
the National Academy of Engineering 14
Grand Challenges etc so many different
possibilities many different challenges
and you have limited bandwidth and
limited resources to look at those
things so which what are the right
technologies to look at and what are the
right problems to focus on is certainly
a key challenge and to today coming to
people I think many of these folks are
very enthusiastic very energetic and I
think the last especially the current
generation they're not afraid of failing
they actually try a lot of things they
don't they're not confirm this so when
they come up with very very good ideas
and our ideas which they believe are
very powerful and very good and when you
have to actually choose from among those
things if you how exactly do you do that
and how do you continue how do you
basically make them see why you have
chosen the ones you have chosen to
invest it and the last thing I would say
is I think innovation itself has become
a very collaborative thing I think the
days of building a product solution and
directly taking to market kind of thing
is faster now most of the innovations
are probably happening in a ecosystem
environment so I think that actually
bring along with it brings a need for
most of the technology people to have
not only technology skills but the
ability to actually work in an ecosystem
the leadership skills the team skills
etcetera etcetera so how do you make
them see the need for some of those
things and build another very good issue
I said Labs has been so successful
that's a great answer
your first point is a great lead-in a
question on what I asked you said there
are so many possible innovations and
technologies out there a big challenge
for you is choosing which ones the focus
would elite you've been a phenomenal
source of new ideas and products if you
like Google Maps this is the guy to
think it's quite remarkable that's just
one of many products he's a lot the
development of your also I know from our
meetings together very thoughtful about
the state of the world and the
challenges if you had to choose one
technology there's only one you know you
to choose one what would that be what
would you want to focus on and what
problem are you trying to respond to and
the particular problem I would choose
which I think will occupy us for the
next probably 20 30 years can be
summarized by you know essentially
applying greens theorem to resources
which is can we find a way to
essentially create an environment where
the six billion on the planet can live
in a developed world where Dell are
remain zero which is the net amount of
incremental resource we use is zero
that's a big ask because we are at a
point where you know the rate of
increase of our is not zero yet so
getting to the point where del R is zero
is a long way away but I think that is
the problem we need to solve one of my
favorite authors is Isaac Asimov and he
wrote this series of books called the
foundation series and in foundation they
discovered that by mathematical modeling
that you know their galaxy is going to
destroy itself because of wars and so
they create this foundation on the edge
of the galaxy called terminus and
turbulence has a peculiar problem where
they have no resources
and terminus innovates itself way out of
all these problems and becomes the
dominant force in the galaxy and then
over time stabilizes the galaxy so in
many ways India to that you know to give
that analogy is sort of like terminus
and I call it the terminus effect where
the early set of innovations you we are
seen which use much smaller amount of
resources like a factor of ten to a
factor of 100 but creating the same kind
of development or starting to happen but
I think we need to take them on as an
institutional challenge and you know do
it on a much larger scale I mean there
are things like you know the cell phone
revolution which everybody is aware of
the smaller cars and so on and so forth
when I graduated from Carnegie Mellon
our valedictorian speech was not
valedictorian but the de no graduation
speech was given by dr. Raja Reddy who
happens to be one of my you know mentors
Freddie being the other one and he said
that you know go forth and solve
problems which impact the illiterate the
handicapped and the poor essentially the
disadvantaged and what was interesting
about the statement he was is he was
talking about the majority of the planet
and I don't think we have solved that
problem and you know the Google Maps
example you gave I won't bore you the
technology but when we moved to this
part of the world we realized that there
are no maps not only in India but in
most of the world and maps are very very
expensive so we had to make generation
of maps one something that users could
do because you know the Bangalore of map
that you have today is outdated within
six months because Bangalore is in hyper
growth and two we had to make it a
factor of hundred cheaper and and the
reason I had personal interest in this
problem is not because you know Maps is
fun which it is but that was not the
reason
the reason is that Maps happens to be
the underpinning for economic growth
there is this Nobel Prize nominee
Hernando DeSoto we were discussing this
this evening who hypothesized that the
key to economic liftoff for developing
countries is to unlock the land that
they are sailing on we capitalized the
undercapitalized landers in India itself
is sitting on by his own estimates
something like 40 trillion dollars
offline and I think easily capitalizable
version is like four trillion and the
key to that is property rights and great
maps and without maps property rights
don't help so and we are starting to see
that effect people told me that today in
Bangalore if you go to be dia and try to
register a development a property
development plan you need to submit a
map and the map comes from Google and so
it's gratifying to see something like
that happening but all of that started
with you know Roger Eddie's speech great
Thank You Olli Pradeep I said before in
my remarks and my introduction to you of
you you've been a great leader education
leader in engineering for Carnegie
Mellon and throughout the country I know
you've also spent a lot of time thinking
about engineering education here in
India and the challenges that are faced
here your observations about education
in India what's going right and what the
challenges are would be valuable I think
and and nicely to the piece of things we
have on the table here Oh
think about this in real time first of
all I'm really pleased to be here so
good to see so many people on the
Carnegie Mellon I think the easy answer
to that question is replicate what we
have done in the US and I'm not saying
this I'm saying this with a lot of
gravity and seriousness and here's the
logic behind this if you look past World
War two
the US has created unprecedented wealth
I mean never in a 40-year
three or a 60 year history has so much
wealth been created in such a
concentrated manner number one number
two that wealth was not only created by
the US but also spread across the whole
world so if you look at this wave of
economic prosperity that we are looking
at now through Europe through Asia
through India in fact there's only one
continent that's not been touched by it
very effectively as it and that's Africa
but it's only a matter of time before it
goes to africa to come back to the US
right and all of this has happened
mainly driven by technology mainly
driven by technology and most of the
technologies a lot of these technologies
clearly are have been created by you
know people like us who are well
educated but most importantly in the
u.s. they've been created at the
university right so here's the litmus
test so take Google for example where
was the core idea of creation of Google
created Stanford University
I thought I was cutting a melon Carnegie
Mellon created the idea before that
always happened it we thought about it
we thought about it they implemented it
right Sun Microsystems the same thing so
there are a lot of mega companies I can
think of that have been created out of
the University now run the same test in
Europe does can anybody tell me one
company in Europe which is worth let's
say more than a hundred billion market
cap that was created at the University
probably not run the same litmus test in
India can somebody tell me one company
and there are many companies in India
who are doing spectacularly well that
was created out of the university like
Google or Sun not really and the problem
is that we don't have in India two
things one is the notion of a great
research university we have great
universities don't get me wrong so don't
confuse a great university education
institution with a great research
university which integrates education
and research and opens up the innovative
potential of people secondly we don't
have very good IP rights I mean we do
have good IP rights in India I don't get
me wrong again but they have to be not
only very good but very strongly
enforced and so we need the notion
vehicle on
what lolly was talking about the map of
IP rights and I mean who created what
when where seriously to enforce it well
and thirdly we need to have a government
policy that integrates research with
economic development creation of
companies encouraging entrepreneurs to
go out there right but all of this is
going to happen first through the
establishment of the creation of a great
research university in the Indian
context a lot of money available out
here a lot of talent available out here
and I think that's what we should be
focusing on and if you do that right it
would have was a very big impact on the
undergraduate education part of the
reason if you went to Carnegie Mellon as
undergrad your undergrad education is so
good and you could go back again ten
years later and be re-educated and not
see the same notes is because we as
faculty integrate research into our
education literally on a yearly basis
new ideas come out the courses get
modified so on and so forth so that
would be my here if you ask me for two
or three words which took me 20 hundred
or 200 words that was very good graces
say thank you pretty so let's get one
more perspective on the table are sure
you're in a unique position because you
serve virtually every significant
company very significant deal around the
world but let's focus on India so you
have a perspective on what their
challenges are what their biggest
problems are and your if you can
summarize your views on that maybe
particularly in the context of the kinds
of where the toy or policy changes you
think would be helpful for your clients
that would be valuable okay Jerry I'll
give you a two-part answer from the
point of view of the companies actually
it's not things like infrastructure of
that or the movements of goods if you
step far enough back in order to gain
perspective I think it really comes into
this issue of developing the talent
proposition I think if you look at the
demographics of India that's really the
key to understand
the future of India and if you look at
that that's both the power and the
challenge and if you look at the
demographics long history long culture
your ancient civilization but it's the
youngest country in the world today in
terms of population median age 23 point
nine one third of the population below
15 years of age so their search that is
coming through I think is the secret to
sustaining India's growth but in order
to realize that potential I think
there's this huge issue of how do you
prepare the people who have the heart or
have the aspiration who have the desire
to engage and so on but the education
issue all the way from primary education
or whether it's vocational or college or
graduate or you know Advanced Research
except for the fact of the few
celebrated examples that we take perhaps
inordinate pride on because they are not
representative of what the reality of
India is I think they are representative
of what India could be I think this is
the issue and over time as India
continues to grow the economy expands
the choke point will come on other
people where the raw talent exists are
they ready to engage and to sustain a
career of innovation and relearning and
re tooling themselves over time that's
the challenge and the second part of it
I would say is again related to the
realities of India which is the
combination of demographics dispersion
of the population two-thirds of the
population lives in rather inaccessible
650,000 villages if you believe that
problems are just the flipside of
opportunity I would say that there's a
huge problem as well as a huge
opportunity
which also by the way provides business
opportunity it is this how do you get
education to the people who are in very
dispersed areas and the full spectrum of
distribution of capabilities all types
of education how do you get modern
styled healthcare to people who are
either underserved or non served and you
can't do it by concentrating doctors and
sending them to very dispersed
populations and it is perhaps also
Financial Inclusion so the reason I've
chosen both these examples is first of
all they are fundamental problems and
therefore opportunities and I think the
way out of that will come out of
innovating new models new ways of
thinking and new solutions which will of
necessity have to leverage technology
but think about in new ways and I think
there are embedded policy implications
of these embedded implications excuse me
for new ways of thinking so that's my
view great I have a question for all of
you I'll pose it but don't answer quite
yet I want you to think about it while I
discuss yet another question is can
there be other Bangalore's in India
are there other Bangalore's growing in
interview there are thoughts about this
valuable to the audience when they're
done having at this question will invite
your questions so please be thinking
about them then we'll invite you to ask
them in just a moment so who'd like to
start
so who do you ever you must have a deep
insight into this cuz no actually like
you said there are people have chosen
banks or I mean they've chosen to come
to Bangalore maybe they can answer but
let me perspective anyway I think at
this point of time you you have will
come to why they have chosen separately
but today if you see there is an entire
ecosystem of companies which is which
are running
out of Bangalore you have and if you
take I'm really talking from a ICT
perspective information and
communication technologies and given
that we normally think of these things
in stacks and layers you have Intel at
the bottom of the stack then you have
companies like Microsoft which are
building operating systems and things
like that then you have left several
infrastructure and product companies and
you have to complete you have many
services companies like Infosys IBM PC
so I think the complete ecosystem is
there and today you probably can think
of newer innovations and then like I
said build them and then take them to
the customers or consumers without
really going anywhere else now or a
period of time maybe in the last 15 to
20 years this has happened why each of
these companies are chosen to come here
maybe there are other there are reasons
like talent and weather and stuff like
that but whatever may be the reason
today this ecosystem got established and
you are able today you can actually come
up with an innovation and build the
entire thing and to it and take to take
to the market crack of that in fact we
were having this conversation just
yesterday at ISC Bangalore I was
visiting bulky and Balram was the
director so if you look at Silicon
Valley for example I think without maybe
with some argument people would merely
agree that the creation of HP was the
seed the big bang that created Silicon
Valley right I mean there were other
companies around it but I think
approximately everybody agrees that so
I've posed this question to balky
yesterday who's the deputy director of
IOT I said what was that seed I mean
what was a big bang that happened in
Bangalore that created this universe
that we know of now and I can tell you
it's a different universe I was here in
1980 and this was like a sleepy Garden
City it was great to live here no house
or you know trees were green
everything was hunky-dory food was cheap
not anymore I don't even recognize a
road so it turns out that there was at
that point an area designated out here
called the export zone and TI decided to
establish its first lab here but for TI
to establish the lab they needed a
satellite link and at that point
remember until like 10 15 years ago
India was a very controlled economy both
mo technology and economy and just from
every point of view goes pretty
socialistic the Chief Minister Bangalore
or whoever that Authority was I don't
quite remember the exact person
basically got them a license to create a
satellite link between TI through a
satellite to TI back in the US and they
said yep this is where we're going to
create the lab because we have the
satellite link that's what we need
because you're moving software back and
forth I see Bangalore at that point then
became very creative and they said oh
you got a satellite link you got
connection to the net we are going to
connect to you now so that we will use
your link so that we will have access to
it
and I think since then it's just now
history that one thing followed the
other marula came soon after because TI
was here and then other companies came
Sumanth soon after because these two
companies were here so that is the
folklore at least and i think it's about
nearly correct it's well nearly as
accurate as HP created Silicon Valley
the Google and etc think about going
elsewhere other than Bangalore was that
just obvious that penguin we actually
started in Mumbai and very soon it
became evident that Bangalore had to be
an important center now we are today in
six cities 18 locations and who knows
how we spread but Bangalore rose was
inviting because for many reasons first
of all I think because of the history of
Bangalore
there was a culture of technical
sophistication and I'll comment on that
a little bit also it's a very very
cosmopolitan environment people here are
I don't know what's the historical
reason but remarkably open-minded they
are they have a global view their
awareness level is very high so it was
easy to move into this environment now
the technical base existed because of
the investments that the government had
been making in public sector industries
which were largely technologically based
and so I think that was a big factor the
weather didn't hurt either by the way
but I think the general ambiance ed in
fact you know I moved I grew up in the
north and I moved back to India
after a long time and my wife loves it
and when i occasionally raise the issue
of so at some stage we'll go back the
question she asked me to think about is
what would it be like to live alone I
think the issue though is that I'll take
a cue from what you said are there other
Bangalore's waiting to be created and I
was so struck by your statement about
the contribution of Carnegie Mellon in
University of Pittsburg to revitalizing
Pittsburg in Bangalore the reality is
though that of all the people who are
working particularly in the
technological and IT industries half of
them are my friends so it is an
unnatural act to force people to move in
and work here it's only because the
other
appropriate or similar opportunities
right now are not elsewhere I think it
will be a more stable situation if while
Bangalore continues to grow we see the
other places as well and I think there
are great if you look historically
we're the evolution of modern India has
been there are many many seats of areas
where I think scholarship was developed
it has the right intellectual climate
etc and I think that's the next wave
because you can only it's like saying
everybody in the u.s. wants to move to
New York City to work out there now they
may be moving there but I think once
other alternatives open up it will be
more even development and then these
places can have the satellite feeders
and secondly thank you
did you want to comment on this no I
love anecdote I think so Google when it
came in I was the junior most member of
the four people so I got to write a
document rationalizing there will go on
so being a CMU graduate I created a
matrix and the soft factors were
actually not so soft turned out so
whether the fact that you have a history
of good schools and Bangalore was
perceived and still is I think one of
the freer cities in India so I can go
out and say things and I can you know be
sort of have free expression and they're
not that many cities in India which have
that character so those don't have to be
very important and it's kind of freaking
AMA quite those things do matter quite a
bit because the other day its people I
think the and and Google when it and
when we did eventually create Google
India we actually split it into two
we R&D was pulling back more for those
reasons and operationally
infrastructurally Bangalore was actually
the worst city we analyzed and for the
Hyderabad happened to be much more
operationally smoother to be little at
least at that time when we form so our
larger office which is
the customer support and so on is order
of magnitude more employees and so I
think in the long room in 10 20 years
from now I think the inversion will
happen in Bangalore I think bangles will
become more and more strong and Ardie
and some of the services will flow out
of anger mainly because of cost of
living another day and rest of India has
the same advantage Bangalore used to
okay re it's your questions shy yes the
role of language and it's the diversity
we have in India how much that's going
to play out in tapping into education or
bring it to fruition its potential as of
today this is a problem that we speak
many languages what's your solution for
that what you take one could be google
translator did you said that's funny he
said it's a free city so maybe you
should answer this political question so
I think I think there are two parts to
the answer I think language will remain
one of India's strengths because
language embeds a ton of cultural
heritage and the different points of
view actually turn out to be an
advantage and the other disadvantages
are gone now having said that the main
disadvantage is that we don't have the
resources to develop educational content
in many languages and I don't think
Google translation is all that fallen so
or any other translation system so I
think what's going to happen is as
seeing the studies of every bunch of
people working in some language center
also chose to send their kids to English
medium schools I think that's going to
be the norm more and more governments
state governments are switching their
kids to English medium sanity is
inglis storm so I think that will happen
and what of them will happen so we will
have I think this strong cultural
heritage so people's is sort of being
trilingual if you will they'll watch
Bollywood in Hindi and educate
themselves in English and then speak the
local language for fun and I think all
of it will work out now there is this
interim period that I'm worried about
purely statistically which is that in
the next twenty ten twenty years while
people are getting educated and worrying
about you know feeding themselves making
sure that the local language is known
whether but I think it's a big enough
country that the risk is low there isn't
the education system already such as
especially the K through 12 level where
kids have to take at least three
languages I mean English the local
language and another secondary language
and then a foreign language and this
foreign language definition is either
French or Sanskrit right the Sanskrit
being the mother of all the European
languages right so that's the case right
now because I think kids take four
languages you're going to comment on the
beeps thing about Sanskrit and then make
a few comments about the regional
languages so I've been for the last
three years trying to find a Sanskrit
teacher you can't there's great people
they're masters of Sanskrit and
Bangalore I want to learn it now because
you are much younger than I so Sanskrit
may have been compulsory it wasn't in my
time however for the language thing I
think for college university education I
don't doubt it at all that English will
rapidly become the preferred medium of
Education but let me take you back to
the demographics of India if you look at
two thirds of the population which is
out in rural areas where today I think
less than forty percent of the school
eligible kids don't get into school so
you know their economic conditions are
poor
the basic medium of communication is
their local language it could be Tamil
it would be Canada Hindi up north I
think at that level if we unless we find
ways to introduce them to education and
primary learning through the language
that they are comfortable with we have a
problem now over time I think maybe
English will become more prevalent but
to Lovett's point about cultural
identity being embedded in the language
I think Indians will not give up their
regional language isn't important that
they don't I see a resurgence so yeah it
is an issue that you can't develop a lot
of content in the regional languages but
at least for purposes of Education I'm
not sure if it is that hard to take the
primary texts and the basic material and
I think there will be people within the
large language clusters who will do it
one way or another the questions this is
a question further but even basically
you made a comment about research
university is emerging in India what can
companies do I understand that convent
has to institute policies and
institutions should know more about IP
rights
I'm just curious your thoughts on how
companies could catalyze how would
companies be catalyzed by this research
companies how can companies help oh
thank you that's a no-brainer
companies can help by investing in this
venture
so let's look at what's going on so
suddenly from five IITs which were the
creme de la creme the elitist the
institutions in this country we decide
there should be more democratic giver
better access to everybody were going to
create seventeen IITs now I guarantee
you these other twelve IITs are having
problems finding qualified to highly
qualified faculty
so now what we have done is diluted
basically a good brand name by adding
more of the same brand but there's a way
to fix it and every company who's
operating in India I think has both in
its own self-interest and as a moral
obligation should be investing in
developing PhDs out here who will do
some good work in the context of the
good work maybe create a company or two
or maybe go to university and be a
faculty and empower the IITs or at least
be good teachers in high school we need
that too right so I think that's how
companies can help by being good
citizens and not just be here for wage
arbitrage or just to increase their a
beta or whatever right you can do that
but and that's another lesson to be
learned I think from American companies
if you look at American companies
whatever city they are in or wherever
their location is they have been
spectacular citizens I mean they
contribute to their locality because
without a healthy locality you're not a
healthy organization they look at it I
am Sahana and I'm a prospective student
for CMU um I was just wondering you were
talking about how universities are need
to be more research oriented what about
high school students because right now
in India education is very textbook
based and she didn't innovation and
inspiring innovations start from when
you are in high school because then
that's when you're going to university
that's when you have these ideas of the
child so isn't that a good time to
inspire kids and what can be done about
that since here I am the battery I think
we have to look at so if you look at our
system right there is way too much
bureaucracy both in terms of content and
in terms of delivery mode and then there
is another layer of bureaucracy which
actually mimics the UK system where you
have these colleges but these colleges
are under a single
universities all Cambridge or Oxford or
University of Paul or something like
that we have to get away from that
create autonomous systems and at the
high school level we have to get away
from rote learning because the rote
learning that starts in high school
propagates itself of the University and
lot of talent and lot of innovation
potential is either killed or loss or
dissipated for no good reason right so I
would think that there has to be a new
forum pedagogy partly because of younger
teachers younger blood coming in and
partly because of education or e-ever or
technology oriented education as in
using computer tools and computer tutors
for individuals like you who seem to be
rather focused and forward-looking and
aggressive to educate and train yourself
to be more innovative in spite of your
high school right in spite of it and I
think this is where Jerry can talk about
or answer this use of technology in
education which is the Kunlun oh she
just want to build on what Pradeep said
and actually that young lady really
asked a very pertinent question because
let's go back to the roots of the
British style system which actually I
started in because my first love was
physics so I got into IIT got in hi I
said I'm not going there told my dad
I'll do physics honours and after one
year I called him and said I'm coming
home and take the exam again I did and
I've hired he my first love again was
physics so the British system of
education actually was designed to
produce clerks would work in offices
just to wrote writing etc so innovation
the ability to sustain yourself over
life and remain intellectually alive has
to be created that it comes from
intellectual confidence and that has to
be created early and it goes counter to
a hierarchical approach to life where
you seek permission and you go with fear
to where there's a sense of
experimentation being able to make
mistakes and say oh that's good myself
up I would say that I think partly there
are things that the culture of India has
to devolve as well because we are more
authoritarian more permissions seeking
culture even the way children are
brought up then I think can sustain the
future and - I think even at the high
school level our approach and curriculum
has to be more flexible
today's approach at least the mainstream
approach by the time you reach about 14
or 15 before you have any idea of what
science and the excitement of science
could be or mathematics or the arts
could be you have to lock yourself into
a stream and then from there on you are
locked into it for life and heaven
forbid that people actually enjoy the
kind of environment that Carnegie the
Carnegie Mellon creates
multidisciplinary the same person being
able to cross from think liberal arts
humanities and at the same time then go
next day and bridge it with mathematics
and science I think we need a revamping
of what education means I would actually
I would actually take the deeps last
comment and treat it as a call to action
for all of us I was fortunate that my
dad trained me that way but I think
those of you I didn't realize they were
high school kids here but those of you
who are still in school I will take it
personally to cultivate your own passion
and cause there's a cause inside each of
us which is waiting to come out so find
it cultivate it and also contain it a
little bit of a reverence because you're
not going to make a difference by just
following what everybody else is star
carding well and you know and and and
the same call to action is to the CMU
graduates who sort of take it for
granted we went to the school
you know you would call faculty by their
first name you know I immediately laughs
when I met dr. Cohen and I called him
Jerry and you know that's that's how we
created a egalitarian environment and I
would encourage you to cultivate that in
your community
I mean or reasons unknown to me people
kind of look up to him your graduates
and you know that's kind of terrible
like given that they do use that and be
a voice for you know people following
their passion and being a voice for to
education which is bringing it out and
you have to to the last comment is a
really good one and I mean just be blunt
about this I think stop calling people
serve because of their rank or hierarchy
do it when you respect them I'm not
saying don't respect your elders we're
just calling somebody sir because he's
your bosses very close yeah great so
half the people who super give fire
tomorrow and they say it's a great
question but I think a lot of that is
changing in my opinion because he talked
about irreverence and things like that
at home by the way yeah good so in fact
I have two of my daughters ago I see
their question papers sometimes in their
assessment they are not like the kind of
papers that we were used to today the
stuff is more like giving a statement
and why do you think it is like this and
many of those things are actually not
there in their textbooks right so a lot
of that is changing especially in
private schools maybe it's not a it's
not common in government schools and
things like that yet but it is actually
forcing them to think what the root
cause is what the reason is and it is
actually encouraging them to ask this
question why and like I said maybe this
questioning is becoming a bit too much
for me at home to my own liking but they
are actually but how representative it
is it is not the 5.1 billion people it's
not I think there has to be a stomach
transformation we agree on that
we only have time for one last mission
someone have the mic already she's got
the mic she would thanks for letting me
be the last letting me ask the last
question
good last night okay I'll make it good
thing I am I'm a recent graduate from
Carnegie Mellon and so I've only been in
Bangalore for about just over a year now
but what has not escaped my attention is
that there are IT parts being built
almost all over the place especially in
areas slightly outside of the city you
know
cities after limits my question is to
any er of all the panelists do you
really think it's a good idea to keep
expanding in a city which is so clogged
up already with a city that really you
know does not have any plan for you know
it has a lack of urban planning is
Bangalore really the future or is or
other cities or areas in India you know
the way to go while they're thinking of
good answers to that question let me
just point out that the theme for our
panel in Mumbai or sustainable
development and an urban design and it's
you know it's a toss-up as to which city
is growing more chaotically Bangalore or
Mumbai it's it was very relevant
question now for every large urban area
but especially in India today so anybody
have a good answer to that question I
don't know if there's a good answer but
I think what is missing is a deep
understanding of policy issues so for
example if you look at cities around the
world there is clearly and a better
understanding now but how innovation
happens and there are cities that are
called innovation clusters where the
state government or the federal
government or the city government
creates this seed you know starts that
initial bang in that big bang theory and
which then leads to a lot of good things
right so for example building around a
university for example building arts and
culture
in a very strong way into a city which
brings more intelligentsia into the city
which brings more educated people into
the city building a university around it
what I see is that most of the cities or
most of our politicians are lacking a
reasonably good understanding of these
policy issues and how to implement and
think about them in the context of their
own cities and their own states and I
think it might be worthwhile of these
politicians took some lesson from a see
stab see step is this think-tank out
here which is created by Carnegie Mellon
faculty it's independent it's on its own
and they're doing some spectacular work
I see a couple of people out here and
might be worth your while to go visit
that place and tell their politicians to
go visit that place it definitely the
city needs a plan right great please
join me in thanking our panelists again
for